>> IF THE FBI WAS SO CONCERNED
AND IF THEY WEREN'T TARGETING
TRUMP, THEY SHOULD HAVE TOLD
TRUMP.
IF THEY'RE REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE RUSSIANS INFILTRATING
A CAMPAIGN, THEN WHY NOT TRY TO
STOP IT?
WHY NOT TELL TRUMP?
WELL, THE ANSWER IS PERFECTLY
CLEAR.
TO ME, THEY WERE RUNNING THIS
WHOLE STORY.
THEY WERE PUSHING THIS SCAM.
>> GREAT INSIGHT.
RUSH LIMBAUGH SAYS THEY SHOULD
HAVE WARNED THE CAMPAIGN.
RUDY GULIANI SAYS TWO THINGS.
CARTER PAGE ON THIS SHOW LAST
NIGHT, MR. MAYOR, THIS WAS THE
SPRING OF 2016.
HE'S NEVER MET DONALD TRUMP.
COMEY'S NOTES, THE SINGLE
BIGGEST UNREPORTED PART OF IT,
TRUMP SAYING TO COMEY, HEY, I
DIDN'T COLLUDE WITH RUSSIA.
IF ANYBODY DID, I WANT TO GET TO
THE TRUTH.
REACTION.
>> WELL, THE FACT IS THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION NEVER SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN PLACE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IF WE CONSIDER THE COUNTER
INTELLIGENCE INVESTIGATION, THE
SPYING, THE SPYGATE, ALL
APPROPRIATE DESCRIPTIONS.
HERE'S WHAT I WANT TO KNOW.
I WANT TO SEE THE DOCUMENTS THAT
TREY GOWDY HAS NEVER SEEN.
I WON'T LET MY CLIENT TESTIFY,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, EVEN IF HE WANTS TO,
WITHOUT THOSE DOCUMENTS BEING
PRODUCED AND MYSELF AND JAY
SEKULOW AND JANE AND MARTY.
WE'RE GOING TO GO OVER IT WITH A
FINE TOOTH COMB.
EVEN AND WHEN WE FIND THAT THIS
WAS HANDLED APPROPRIATELY AND
THERE'S SOME EVIDENCE ON WHICH
THEY CAN BASE THIS PHONY
INVESTIGATION WILL WE HAVE HIM
TESTIFY.
IF THERE IS NO EVIDENCE, WHICH I
ASSUME THERE IS NO EVIDENCE,
THEN I MEAN, HE SHOULDN'T
TESTIFY.
THE WHOLE THING SHOULD BE
SQUASHED.
SHOULD BE ENDED IMMEDIATELY.
AND WE'LL CHALLENGE MUELLER TO
WRITE WHATEVER YOU GOT, TAKE
YOUR BEST PUNCH WITH YOUR 13
DEMOCRATS THERE, YOU COULDN'T
FIND A REPUBLICAN.
>> Sean: ANDREW WISEMAN.
>> HOW ABOUT AN INDEPENDENT?
HOW ABOUT GUYS WITH ETHICAL
ISSUES AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
I KNOW THAT.
I WAS A HIGH-RANKED OFFICIAL IN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
SO YOU HAVE A GROUP THERE, A
LYNCHING MOB, SO LET THEM DO
THEIR JOB AND WE'RE READY TO
KNOCK THE HECK OUT OF YOU WITH
OUR REPORT, WHICH WILL BE
AUTHORITATIVE, BACKED UP, BACKED
UP WITH LAW AND FACTS.
WE'LL LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DECIDE THIS.
YOU KNOW, SOME PEOPLE HAVE
CRITICIZED MY STRATEGY, WHICH IS
THE PRESIDENT'S, TO SOME EXTEND
PLAYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF THIS WERE A REGULAR CASE, I
WOULDN'T BE DOING IT.
THE PEOPLE THAT WILL DECIDE THIS
IS ARE THE PEOPLE OF THE UNITED
STATES IN THE ELECTION.
THEY'RE SWITCHING FAST AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING FOR COVER.
YOU DON'T HEAR IMPEACHMENT
ANYMORE.
I CHALLENGE MAXINE WATERS TO SAY
IMPEACH IT.
SAY IT.
YOU'RE GOING TO GO DOWN.
THEY VOTE FOR YOU, I DON'T KNOW
WHY BUT THEY VOTE FOR YOU.
YOUR COLLEAGUES WILL GO DOWN,
THIS IS THE CHANGE THAT WE
BROUGHT ABOUT BY ENGAGING AND
NOT LETTING THEM GET AWAY WITH
THE UNETHICAL BEHAVIORS THAT HAS
OUTRAGED JUDGE ELLIS, JUDGE
WOOD.
SHE THREW AWAY THE LEFT WING
STAR FROM MSN AND NBC OUT OF
COURT.
HE DOESN'T BELONG IN A NEW YORK
HE'S NOT ETHICAL ENOUGH.
YOU KNOW WHY?
HE'S A BIG LIAR.
HE WANTED TO DEBATE ME.
LIKE HECK.
HE SHOULD GO DEBATE IN SOME GIN
MILL.
>> Sean: YOU SAID IT EARLIER AND
CONFIRMING TONIGHT THAT IF
MR. MUELLER SUBPOENAS THE
PRESIDENT, WE WILL FIGHT THIS TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
THE CONSTITUTION IS ON THE
PRESIDENT'S SIDE.
JUDGE ELLIS' COMMENTS, GOING
BACK TO 2005 TAX CASE WITH
UKRAINE
UKRAIN
UKRAINE, PAUL MANAFORT TO PUT
THE SCREWS TO THE PRESIDENT SO
MANAFORT SINGS OR COMPOSES, AND
THE HOPES THAT THEY CAN
PROSECUTE OR IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> SEAN, I HAVE NO FEAR OF IT,
NOR DOES THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE NOTHING
WRONG.
READ MY LIPS, NOTHING WRONG.
SO THEY CAN -- NONE OF THESE
PEOPLE, MANAFORT, COHEN, THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO LIE.
THEY CAN GO POUND SOUND.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LIE.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT THE SPYING
AND THE FISA COURT ABUSE?
>> YOU HAVE TO GO TO JAIL FOR
THAT.
IT'S ONE THING TO LIE EVEN IN A
CRIMINAL CASE.
ANOTHER THING TO LIE IN A
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE PROBE.
ALSO, THE FISA JUDGES RELY EVEN
MORE THAN A CRIMINAL COURT --
>> Sean: ROD ROSENSTEIN SIGNED
THE FINAL APPLICATION.
SALLY YATES SIGNED ONE.
>> SO WHAT?
SO WHAT?
>> Sean: THE BULK OF IT WAS
HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR, FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE BIT
RUSSIAN LIES AND THEY NEVER
CORROBORATED IT.
>> I'LL FOLLOW UP ON WHAT RUSH
SAID.
OF COURSE IF IT WASN'T SPYING,
THEY SHOULD HAVE COME TO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEY COULD HAVE COME TO ME.
I WAS THE FBI MAN OF THE YEAR
THAT YEAR.
THEY COULD HAVE COME TO ME AND
THEY COULD HAVE TOLD ME AND I
COULD HAVE BRIEFED THE PRESIDENT
OR THEY COULD HAVE BRIEFED THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN IN
THE SPRING OF 2016.
THE PRESIDENT NEVER MET CARTER
PAGE, EVER TO THIS DAY.
>> HE HASN'T MET MOST OF THESE
PEOPLE THAT THEY ALLEGED -- AND
THEY HAVEN'T ALLEGED COLLUSION
ON THE PART OF ANYBODY.
THE EVEN RUSSIANS, THE PHONY
INDICTMENT WITH THE RUSSIANS
THAT WILL NEVER COME FOR TRIAL.
THEY COLLUDED WITH EACH OTHER.
RUSSIANS COLLUDING.
BIG NEWS.
THEY HAVE BEEN COLLUDING SINCE
THE SOVIET UNION.
THANK YOU, SEAN.
THANKS FOR BEING A PATRIOT.
THE PRESIDENT APPRECIATES IT.
>> Sean: IT'S ABOUT THE TRUTH
AND IT'S THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER.
CORRUPTION SCANDAL.
EVERYTHING WE TALK ABOUT --
>> DON'T THINK --
>> Sean: SPYING ON A CAMPAIGN.
>> DON'T THINK HE HAS ANY
RELUCTANCE TO BE INTERVIEWED.
HE'S READY AND WILLING TO BE
INTERVIEWED.
IT'S ME AND HIS LAWYERS --
>> Sean: I WOULDN'T ALLOW THIS
PRESIDENT TO GO ANYWHERE NEAR
ANY SPECIAL COUNSEL THAT HIRES A